this is DeAndre Hopkins store bench cut
let's get it start remember the Titans
cut Friday Night Lights [ __ ] Rudy I
like everything that moves nted but
remember the tight ends everyone
everybody together and Rudy is a classic
so imma go you know it's a timely matter
start Matt and Kurt GTA Vince call of
duty
I'm gonna go [ __ ] call of duty because
I probably only get like five kills the
game so you know man pull myself and I
win a lot and I GTA it's pretty long so
I'm about to cut that one I know it I
know man
you die trying start the car the three
[ __ ] The Blueprint I'm gonna cut give
it to that time you know the Wayne Wayne
that's just when my favorite rapper
jay-z come on you know and then 50 it's
some peers from that but I'm at the
bench 50 star Tom Brady you know
champion football it's the hearts for
the win when any anything against better
yet it's many temperatures you want I'm
a bench my best arena i'ma cut tiger I
love a tiger but I Serena what she's
done
not a lot one that has accomplished
I'm DeAndre Hopkins this was star bench
cut
I'm here with Carl's jr. and Hardee's
promoting the behind the game campaign
make sure you go Monday and purchase
your lawyers ring and don't forget to
use the Cole we're beyond the game to
get your free beyond the meat item see
y'all later